Oh, was jetzt?
Was, was
letzter Stream?
Jetzt wieder? Was letzter
Stream, Chat? Ja, okay.
Nice. Excellent.
Excellent.
Very gut.
Aber Chat, ich habe ja noch
keinen Plan, warum es nicht geht.
Vielleicht seid ihr SixHead
und pusht du das
später. Ja, kann ich machen.
Ich würde es ja gerne pushen,
wenn es funktioniert.
Aber ich kann es auch so
pushen, aber ich habe echt...
Du hast geguckt, das ist Stream 0
genau richtig. Okay.
Einmal irgendwas falsch rum hier.
End Duration
Buffer Size
Pointer.
Äh.
Haben wir nicht.
Duration ist das
zweite.
Warte mal. Moment.
Das ist das zweite. Passt schon.
Vielleicht liegt es echt an dem Video.
Vielleicht liegt das...
Ich meine, es könnte ja echt
an dem Video liegen.
Ich bin gerade etwas
planlos.
Vielleicht geht es auch irgendwann einfach so random.
Die Bufferlänge ist in
Bytes.
Also Anzahl Bytes.
Okay, vielleicht stirbt mit dem Video
irgendwas nicht.
Ich meine, wir haben es re-encoded.
Ich meine, allzu viel verkehrt
kann da nicht sein.
Oh, Baseline.
Okay.
Versuch mal mit Pixelformat.
Äh. Wieso? Ist es doch.
Ist es doch.
Did you try reducing video duration?
Maybe it's too large.
I calculate the video
the frame duration
with the values from FFmpeg.
And
16 milliseconds
seems right for
a 60 FPS
Video.
I think my video...
Video is in the wrong format.
Ist ja was.
Wir probieren mal was aus.
Also.
Wir machen jetzt erst noch mal eine Sache.
Nehmen wir das jetzt mal.
Ultra Fast Interments.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wir speichern das mal in einem TS-File.
Einfach nur, dass kein MP...
Ich meine, MP4 ist an der Stelle komplett
weg.
Muss man ja auch mal sagen. Also MP4 ist komplett
raus. Das geht über einen
RTSP-Stream rein. Das hat mit
MP nichts zu tun.
Aber...
Aber man weiß ja nicht.
Was hast du vor?
Videos streamen in meinen Browser
über WebRTC.
Und ich hab das schon mal mit Go gemacht.
Das funktioniert.
Aber...
Jetzt gerade nicht.
Und ich glaube jetzt langsam liegt es echt
an dem Videotrack.
Probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus.
Wann das...
Aber das mit dem Pixelformat ist nicht verkehrt.
Aber das...
Es ist ja eigentlich schon im...
Es ist ja eigentlich schon im richtigen Pixelformat.
Also...
Okay.
FFmpeg...
Ich glaube es liegt am Video.
Ich bräuchte einen Capture von einem meiner
Webcams.
Aber...
Das kann ich nicht machen, weil...
Wonka Leak.
Äh...
Okay.
Hä?
Ich hab doch nichts geändert?
Also...
Wir haben jetzt...
Wir haben jetzt das Video in einer anderen Datei
gespeichert im Endeffekt. Aber...
Der Container
ist doch vollkommen egal an der
Stelle. Davon ist doch überhaupt nichts
mehr übrig.
Looted.
Auto.
Play.
Okay.
Ich bin sehr...
Wartet mal.
Jetzt nachdem das Video läuft.
Output MP4 hauen wir jetzt mal rein.
Okay.
Das geht nicht.
Es macht keinen Sinn.
Das ist mit...
Der Container hat nichts mit dem
zu tun, was der da abspielt.
Der liest die einzelnen Frames raus.
Die H264...
Der weiß überhaupt nichts mehr davon.
Achso.
Ich muss neu starten.
Guck mal.
Jetzt geht's auch wieder nicht mehr.
Doch.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Okay.
Leute.
Der muss irgendwas anderes encoded haben.
Irgendwas hat er verkehrt encoded.
In dem MP4 Video.
Wir müssen...
Wir müssen mal den...
Wir müssen mal vergleichen, was FFprobe da sagt.
Also...
Das...
Warum...
Hä?
MP4 hat doch damit überhaupt gar nichts mehr zu tun, Mann.
Okay.
FFprobe.
Output.
Kann FFprobe mehrere Sachen?
Nee.
Ja.
Okay.
Das ist alles wurscht.
Das hier ist das Stream.
Das ist das Interessante.
Input.
Duration.
Bitrate.
Ja.
Die Bitrate ist ein bisschen anders.
Duration ist exakt gleich.
Ja.
Constraint.
Das ist das, worauf es ankommt.
Baseline.
Okay.
Blablabla.
Was ist das?
16...
16 FPS.
Es ist doch genau das gleiche da drin, Mann.
What?
Könnte eventuell am Filter liegen?
Welch...
Wo?
An welcher Stelle soll da ein Filter sein?
Ich mein, der Output ist doch genau das gleiche.
Dieser ganze Mist.
Diese ganzen...
Dieses ganze Metadaten-Zeug.
Das ist im Output überhaupt nicht mehr...
Also, davon sieht mein Browser nie was.
Was?
Add this to your command.
Äh, das haben wir ja auch.
Alles...
Alles Mist.
Das hat damit doch gar nichts zu tun.
Okay.
Ich mein, das mache ich jetzt...
Ich mein, es ist gut zu wissen, dass es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Ich habe...
Ich mein, das muss...
Das...
Das muss mit kaputten China-Chinesen-Videos funktionieren, Mann.
Ja.
Wo soll ich das adden?
Hier.
Wo ist das F...
Ja, Moment.
Wo...
Wo hatten wir das jetzt hier gerade?
Ja.
Video-Codec.
Es ist sogar schon im richtigen Format.
Also, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, warum das in...
Wie gesagt, es ist gut zu wissen, dass es funktioniert.
Es...
Aus meiner Sicht...
Leuchtet es nicht ein.
Weil der Video-Stream...
Ist doch genau der gleiche.
Egal, ob...
MP4 oder...
Oder...
TS.
Das könnte auch...
Was weiß ich...
Das könnte auch MOF...
Könnte das sein oder so.
Spätestens an der Stelle, wo jetzt der Video-Stream an den RTSP-Server geschickt wird, ist MP4
doch schon weg.
Moment.
Beim Abspielen könnte sein, dass...
Leute.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das könnte sein, dass...
Leute.
Das liegt nicht an meinem Video-Format, das liegt an FFM-Pack beim Abspielen.
FFM-Pack beim Senden an den...
An den RTSP-Server macht da komisches Zeug.
Das...
Das wird's wahrscheinlich sein.
Ja das ist genau wieder das gleiche hier.
FFM-Pack...
Guck' mal nochmal.
Ja.
Das funzt nicht?
Das liegt...
Das liegt aber nicht an mir.
Also nicht an dem Videofile.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, das liegt an dem Senden
zum RTSP-Server.
Output.
Da gucken wir mal, was der Unterschied ist jetzt dazwischen.
From Output MP4.
Hier.
Was ist der Unterschied?
Ich sehe da jetzt keinen drin.
Ich ziehe die ein.
Das da zu...
Okay, hier sind irgendwelche Zusatzdinger gesetzt.
Hier sind irgendwelche Zusatzdinger gesetzt, ohne dass ich...
Also der hintere Kram ist gleich.
Hier vorne ist noch irgendein Zusatzkrempel gesetzt.
Wo ich nicht weiß, was es heißen soll, ehrlich gesagt.
Es könnte aber auch sein, dass es das gleiche heißt,
nur hier nichts anzeigen kann.
Du hast Sprache geflamed, Beste.
Ach, moin.
Moin.
Du hast Glück.
Vodafone hat gerade übelst rumgespackt.
Und Stream ist abgekackt.
Ich bin jetzt aber auch gleich weg.
Aber zumindest es funktioniert.
Ich bin begeistert, Chat.
Ich weiß nicht...
Übrigens, Leute.
Mal so ein kurzer Spoiler.
Kurzer Spoiler.
Der Paketo und ich, wir haben geplant,
wir kennen uns so um mehrere Ecken.
Wir haben geplant, mal mit euch
einen Kubernetes-Security-Programm zu machen.
Wir haben geplant, mal mit euch einen Kubernetes-Security-Programm zu machen.
Oder was in der Richtung.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir das Ganze aufbauen.
Er ist nämlich Consultant für Kubernetes-Security.
So was gibt es auch.
ForceChamp, ja.
Massive.
Also.
Ich zeige euch jetzt nochmal abschließend,
bevor ich abhaue, dass es funktioniert.
Oh, zack.
Zack.
Hoffentlich brage.
Hoffentlich funktioniert.
Moment.
Hoffentlich geht es.
Pass auf.
Wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt kaputt und es funktioniert wieder nicht.
Doch.
Videospiel ab.
Also Leute, ich habe keinen Plan.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung,
warum das mit MP4 nicht geht,
aber mit TS funktioniert.
Es leuchtet mir ums Verrecken nicht ein.
Das muss wahrscheinlich...
Also ich glaube nicht,
dass es an der Videodatei liegt.
Das muss daran liegen,
dass FFmpeg das zum RTSP-Server schickt.
Dass das irgendwie...
Irgendwas wirres macht.
Irgendwas ganz komisch konvertiert.
Und es deswegen nicht geht.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber prinzipiell funktioniert das WebRTC-Stream.
Wann machst du den Stream zu Kubernetes?
Das haben wir uns noch nicht näher überlegt.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Noch nicht geklärt.
Aber ich werde das schon im Vorfeld mal erzählen,
dass keiner verpasst.
Das war es.
Dann habt ihr einen,
der euch auch mal was erklären kann.
Der ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung hat als ich,
was Kubernetes-Security-Sachen angeht.
Ihr kennt mich ja.
Ich schalte ja immer möglichst viel Security aus,
dass es besser funktioniert.
Das ist...
Ihr wisst doch, wie das ist.
Wer ist instant perfekt einrichtet
und immer fehlerfrei,
der muss nichts testen
und er muss nichts dokumentieren.
Und nachdem er in dem Stream hier immer alles,
wie man heute gesehen hat,
prinzipiell alles komplett fehlerfrei funktioniert,
ist es logisch.
Dann braucht man das nicht.
Zum Experimentieren Minikube.
Ob ich dir das empfehlen würde?
Ja, würde ich dir empfehlen.
Würde ich dir empfehlen.
Also ich persönlich mag Minikube.
Falls der Paket nur noch da ist,
wir können ihn fragen, was er empfehlen würde
zum Experimentieren mit Kubernetes.
Also ich bin ja Minikube-Fan.
Manche schwören auf K3S.
Wahrscheinlich hängt es ein bisschen von ab,
was man machen muss.
Beziehungsweise was man machen will.
Ich mag Minikube einfach,
weil man sagen kann,
zack, Minikube, delete, alles wieder weg.
Zack, Minikube, start.
Und guck mal, jedes Lokal wieder da.
Kube-CTL und so alles schon eingerichtet
und funktioniert.
Ubuntu oder Fedora?
Ehrlich gesagt, nix von beidem.
Also für was? Desktop?
Auf dem Desktop würde ich es nicht verwenden.
Auf dem Server? Ubuntu.
Man guckt, zack, hat man einen Cluster am...
Cluster, Cluster ist viel gesagt.
Ja, lokales Bastel-Kubernetes am Start.
Und wenn man fertig ist, sagt man delete
und es ist wieder fort.
So.
Chat, wenn mir irgendjemand erklären kann,
wenn irgendjemand was gesehen hat,
was ich nicht gesehen habe,
was der Unterschied ist,
da gibt es gratis Sub,
was der Unterschied ist
zwischen dem mp4-File
und dem TS-File.
Ich habe absolut gar keine Ahnung.
Start und Bitrate.
Nee, das ist...
Ist es nicht.
Das kann es nicht sein.
Das ist exakt der gleiche Video-Stream.
Okay, also, also, die Endung.
Die Endung ist weg, spätestens wenn es
an den RTSP-Server geschickt wird.
Also, wir machen jetzt mal eine Sache.
Um festzustellen,
ob es irgendwie an den Video-Files liegt.
Und zwar,
wir kopieren
den Video-Stream.
Wir kopieren den Video-Stream
aus dem einen File,
in blub.mp4, okay?
Ein Diff auf ein Video-File,
was zweimal encoded wurde.
Ja, das...
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so die beste Idee.
So, fertig.
Also, zack.
Ja, blub.
Hoffentlich geht das jetzt.
Wenn es nicht geht,
habe ich keine Ahnung.
Aber ich wollte eh pennen, klar.
Es geht.
Okay, dann liegt das...
Dann liegt das nicht an
dem MP4er, was er hochlädt,
sondern aus irgendwelchen Gründen
encoded FFM-Pack,
wenn er weiß, dass man
H.264 in einen MP4-Container
encoded,
den Stream ein bisschen anders,
als wie wenn man ihn in einen TS...
What the fuck? Ich hab...
Okay, keine Ahnung. Ich will's nicht wissen.
Ich...
Keine Ahnung, was das Ding für Schmerzen hat.
Mach...
Mofflex-Faster.
Aber davon sieht der Browser doch gar nichts.
Aber ich mach das.
Ich kann das machen.
Ja, das testen wir jetzt als letztes noch.
Wenn du mir noch sagst,
wie man Options setzt...
Das weiß ich nämlich aus dem Kopf
am besten Willen nicht.
Hier.
Lob 2.MP4.
FF...
FFM-Pack.
Wie geht denn das?
Hier.
Minus Mofflex.
Alles klar.
Obviously.
Wäre das die Cringe, wer das nicht weiß.
Danach muss ich den Ordner wieder löschen.
Ich habe unsinnigerweise gerade irgendwie
8 Gig Videos oder so hier rumliegen.
Wobei, nee, so groß ist das nicht.
Ein paar Minuten 8 Mbit.
Ist nicht so groß.
Kannst du im C Sharp die Framegröße anzeigen?
Du meinst die Dimension?
Oder du meinst die Größe in Bytes?
Die Größe in Bytes haben wir uns schon anzeigen lassen.
Es ist irgendwo um 20k rum oder so.
Das kommt schon hin.
Ich kann das machen.
Also Dimensionen bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Ich glaube, das kann man.
Das hat man hier nicht.
Ich glaube, dazu muss man das decoden,
dass man das weiß.
Wobei, nee, muss man nicht.
Keine Ahnung, wie man das auslesen kann.
Aber ich kann euch die Größe zeigen hier.
Size.
Zack.
So.
Jetzt haben wir das mit dem Fast Start drinnen.
Dann probieren wir das nochmal.
Loop 2.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Und und.
Es geht nicht.
Das liegt irgendwie encodet ja das wir.
Guck um die 20k haben wir ungefähr.
Das ist nicht.
Das kann auch nicht am Container liegen.
Aber es ist egal, Leute.
Wurscht, egal, weil prinzipiell geht's und das Stream von der von der China Kamera wird auch funktionieren.
Moin, Luko, bist genau richtig.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen oder zumindest oder zumindest gehe ich auf morgen früh ganz normal.
Irgendwann zwischen 8.30 Uhr und 9.30 Uhr bin ich am Start.
Kacke heute das Vodafone, dass wieder der Stream abgekackt ist.
Na und hier.
Das hat man davor 205 oder sowas Viewer das gleich gedroppt.
Die ganzen Lurker sind weg, weil er, weil der Stream abgekackt ist.
Naja.
Also morgen zwischen 8.30 Uhr und 9.30 Uhr wieder am Start.
Naja, Sonntag.
Sonntag eine Stunde länger pennen, sonst stehe ich 7.30 Uhr auf.
Wobei Chat, Chat, Moment, Moment.
Ich gehe ja morgen wieder eine Runde rennen.
Also eventuell auch ein paar Minuten später, aber 9.30 Uhr kommt ganz gut hin.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich die große 10 Kilometer Runde mache.
Morgen habe ich irgendwie keinen Bock.
Wetter, Wetter sieht auch nicht so geil aus.
Ich weiß, du bist Sonntag morgens nieder.
Es sind aber erstaunlich viele Leute Sonntag vormittags immer da.
Hast du schon Diablo 4 gespielt?
Habe ich großen Bogen drum gemacht, nachdem ich die ersten paar Sachen gesehen habe.
Obwohl das Game ja, glaube ich, gar nicht so übel ist.
Für, man spielt es mal dreimal durch auf den Schwierigkeitskran und dann ist es gut.
Wobei, ich glaube, das hat gar keine so normalen Schwierigkeitskran, wie man das von den alten Diablos kennt.
Äh, das habe ich, ganz ehrlich, normalerweise würde ich jetzt sagen, das habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Aber sowas habe ich eigentlich nie regelmäßig gemacht.
Ich bin schon immer eher jemand gewesen, der früh pennen geht und früh aufsteht.
Wie gefällt dir Baldur's Gate 3? Richtig gut.
Baldur's Gate 3, ich habe es immer noch nicht durchgespielt, weil der dritte Akt etwas unfertig wirkt, ja.
Ich hatte dann auch irgendwann keinen Bock mehr.
Also man merkt schon, dass das Polish in Akt 1 und 2 eine ganze Ecke höher ist, als in Akt 3.
Aber, wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste, so bei klassischen RPGs, die in den letzten Jahren über rausgekommen sind.
Da muss ich ehrlich sagen, so die letzten zwei Jahre, da ist Pathfinder, Wrath of the Righteous rausgekommen und Baldur's Gate 3, so von den größeren Titeln.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen, es sind sehr unterschiedliche Games, ja.
Aber für meinen Geschmack gefällt mir das Pathfinder-Game besser.
Das ist deutlich Kampf-, also Fight-heavier.
Baldur's Gate 3 ist halt deutlich mehr Roleplay-Dialog.
Und Sachen drumherum.
Leider haben beide Games das Problem, dass sie zum Ende hin ziemlich abbauen.
Falls irgendjemand mal ein Game spielen will, also was Production Value und Story und Komplexität und Grafik mit Baldur's Gate 3 bei weitem nicht mithalten kann.
Aber, falls einer mal eine wirklich gute Dungeons & Dragons 5th Edition Umsetzung sehen will in einem Game, dem kann ich...
...das hier empfehlen auf Steam.
Das ist so ziemlich, so ziemlich die beste...
Ach, die Grafik ist halt grausam, ja.
Aber das ist so ziemlich die beste 5th Edition Umsetzung, die ihr als Game finden werdet.
Also, da merkt man auch, was in Baldur's Gate 3 eigentlich alles fehlt an Optionen, die man im Kampf so hat.
Aber dafür hat Baldur's Gate 3 eine ganz andere Stärke.
Also, es hängt ein bisschen davon ab, was man gerne mag.
Ja.
Also, ich würde sagen, generell vom Gameplay her und vom Aufbau her finde ich Breath of the Righteous ist ein super Game geworden.
Für alle Roleplayer, die auch gerne abseits von Kämpfen so ein bisschen Dialoge haben und auch viele unterschiedliche Ausgangs...
...unterschiedliche Optionen haben wollen.
So nach dem Motto, wie man mit dem Spielgang ist, Baldur's Gate 3.
Und wer mal Dungeons & Dragons pur spielen will, 5th Edition, der kann sich so Laster angucken.
Alternativ?
Einfach alle drei Sachen spielen, weil...
Warum nicht?
Ist nicht so, als könnte man sich das nicht leisten.
So teuer sind die Games nicht.
Für das, was man bekommt an Spielzeit.
Wohlgemerkt.
Yep.
Alles klar, Leute.
Hoffentlich hat's Vodafone auf die Reihe bekommen morgen früh.
Ich geh jetzt pennen.
Bis denn.
Boomer müde.
Boomer schlafen.
Bad kid time.
Wir sehen uns. Bis denn.
See you.